vamos a trabajar con el problema 17 el
problema 17 que está en la página a 463
de este libro y estos problemas que
tienen operaciones raras y figuras
extrañas como me gustan fíjate bien lo
que dice este problema dice la operación
flecha arriba está definida de la
siguiente manera a flecha arriba ve a
flechar la ve es exactamente lo mismo
que a más b / a menos b / a menos b para
a distinta de b y bueno esto es muy
importante porque si fuera igual a ver
tendríamos una división entre 0 y no se
puede dividir entre 0 y entonces nos
preguntan si tenemos la ecuación 1
flecha arriba 2 esto es igual a 2 flecha
arriba
entonces cuánto vale x y bueno
esencialmente lo que hay que hacer es
tomar la definición de esta función de
cómo definimos a la función flecha
arriba y sustituir tanto aa como a b
porque por ejemplo en este caso tenemos
1 flecha arriba 2 por lo tanto am va a
ser igual a 1 y b va a ser igual a 2
entonces que nos quedaría 1 flecha
arriba 2 por la definición de la función
me va a quedar pero a vale 1 entonces va
a ser uno más b es decir más 2 entre am
a vale 1 entre 1 menos ven pero ve vale
2 - 2 y esto tiene que ser igual por
otra parte a esta otra función flecha
arriba que por cierto recuerda que este
ahora va a ser am
y éste ahora va a ser ve y entonces
vamos a escribirlo según la definición
de la función flecha arriba me queda que
am es decir dos más x esto entre a menos
b
2 - x 2 - x y aquí ya tengo una ecuación
la cual puedo resolver para x fíjate que
uno más dos es 33 entre 1 - 2 lo cual es
menos 13 entre a menos 1 esto es igual a
2 más x entre 2 - x tengo una ecuación
con una incógnita y bueno 3 entre menos
1 esto es lo mismo que a lo puedo
escribir como menos tres menos tres es
igual a esta función que tengo aquí y
entonces qué va a pasar si ahora
multiplico ambos lados de esta ecuación
por 2 - x voy a multiplicar este lado
por dos menos x
voy a multiplicar este lado por 2 - x y
bueno esto sabiendo que x es distinto de
2 porque justo esto es lo que me dice la
operación flecha arriba que a no puede
ser igual
avn por lo tanto 2 no puede ser igual a
equis y esto tiene toda la razón porque
si x fuera 2 me quedaría una división
entre 0
jr si multiplicamos todo por 2 - x y que
me va a quedar de este lado 2 - x y 2 -
x se van y solamente me quedan dos más x
mientras que del lado izquierdo me va a
quedar menos 3 que multiplica a 2 - x y
bueno vamos a distribuir este 3 este por
este este por este y me queda menos 6
menos por más menos 3 por 2 6 menos por
menos más más 3 x más 3 x esto es igual
a 2
muy bien y ahora qué pasa si yo sumo
seis de ambos lados de la ecuación me va
a quedar que 3x es igual a 26 lo cual es
8 + equis y ahora si yo restó x de ambos
lados de la ecuación me va a quedar que
2x esto es igual a 8 y ya casi acabamos
si ahora dividido entre 2 ambos lados de
esta igualdad me va a quedar que x es
igual a 4 y por cierto esta es la
respuesta del problema 17 que es el
inciso y ya está tenemos aquí la
respuesta del problema de 17 y bueno
pues vamos a hacer el siguiente problema
que por cierto ya estamos cerca de la
recta final de esta parte del examen la
sección 3 del examen todos está a punto
de acabar así que déjenme cambiar de
color me voy a tomar un color más
llamativo y vamos a hacer la parte de 18
acercándonos a la recta final
+ 18 y este problema tiene que ver con
dinero así que mejor voy a usar el color
verde de dinero y dice durante una
subasta un cliente puede comprar una
playera por equis pesos entonces estamos
hablando de pesos una playera voy a
ponerlo aquí una playera la puede
comprar por equis pesos una playera se
compra en x pesos y después de esta
playera cada playera adicional cuesta 7
pesos menos que la primera playera
entonces cada playera adicional
adicional adicional cuesta 7 pesos menos
entonces menos
z pesos por ejemplo el costo de la
segunda es x z el costo de la tercera
también va a ser x z el coste de la
cuarta también va a ser x z cualquier
playera adicional que compres a la
primera playera cuesta x 7 entonces lo
voy a poner aquí cualquier player
adicional cuesta x menos z pesos muy
bien y ahora lo que me preguntan es lo
siguiente cuál de las siguientes
expresiones es la adecuada para
representar el precio de la compra de n
playeras durante estas rebajas y bueno
quiero que te des cuenta de lo siguiente
si yo compro una playera entonces por la
primera playera voy a pagar x pesos esto
es lo que cuesta la primera playera pero
después de ella
la segunda playera cuesta x menos z
pesos la tercera también va a costar x
menos 7 pesos y todas las demás después
de la primera playera cuestan x
siete pesos por lo tanto esto me va a
quedar como x más y yo lo que yo saber
son cuánto cuestan en playeras pero de
éstas en playeras ya sé que la primera
playera vale x pesos a n le voy a quitar
1 me va a quedar más en menos 1 por lo
que cuestan todas las demás playeras
después de la primera playera es decir
cada una de ellas cuesta x menos z pesos
vamos a ver un pequeño ejemplo por
ejemplo si yo quiero saber cuánto
cuestan cuatro playeras pues la primera
playera la voy a pagar en x pesos la
segunda playera la voy a pagar en x
menos eta pesos la siguiente playera la
voy a pagar en x menos eta pesos la
siguiente playera también la voy a pagar
en x menos z pesos recuerdan que estamos
comprando cuatro playeras entonces esta
es mi primer player am esta expresión de
aquí es lo que vale la segunda playera
estas de la segunda
esto es lo que cuesta a la tercera esto
es lo que cuesta la cuarta sin embargo
date cuenta que aquí estoy contando una
dos tres veces la misma cantidad de
dinero por lo tanto esto no quedaría
como x más tres veces porque estoy
contando tres veces lo mismo tres veces
x menos z pesos si yo quiero comprar
cuatro playeras lo que voy a pagar es x
más uno menos que 4 que es 3 x x - zeta
si yo lo que quiero comprar es n
playeras lo que voy a pagar es x + y
después le restamos 1 a n y hay que
multiplicarlo por el precio de lo que
valen todas las demás playeras así que
esta es mi respuesta que por cierto es
el inciso a estos el inciso am y ya está
aquí en el problema número 18 perfecto
vámonos al siguiente problema el
problema número 19 y déjame borrar la
pantalla y aquí
a poner el problema número 19 y en este
problema me dan una figura muy parecida
a ésta que creo que se puede hacer a
mano tengo una línea por aquí tengo otra
línea por acá parecida a ésta y después
tengo este ángulo y este ángulo me dicen
que es de 30 grados y después me dicen
que aquí tengo el punto p aquí tengo el
punto cu y por acá tengo el punto era
muy bien y dice en la figura siguiente q
r es un arco del círculo con centro en p
es decir tenemos un círculo con centro
en p si la longitud de q r de q r está
longitud
6 esta es 6 p entonces lo que me
preguntan es cuál es el área del sector
p dicho de otra manera lo que me están
preguntando es cuál es esta área de este
sector pero bueno vamos a visualizar lo
de la siguiente manera me gusta que
utilicemos esta herramienta porque
quiero que lo veas el problema ha
visualizado de una manera completa yo
tengo un círculo entonces voy a suponer
que este es mi círculo lo voy a dibujar
por aquí este va a ser mi círculo y por
cierto este círculo tiene como centro a
p entonces por aquí está mi centro y
este punto es que es mi centro y esta
figura de aquí p q r el sector p como si
le llamaron es más o menos esta que voy
a dibujar aquí tengo este de aquí y un
pedazo más o menos así un pedacito
parecido a éste y bueno yo tengo que
éste
es 30 grados 30 grados este punto sería
que este otro punto sería r y ahora lo
que yo quiero saber es cuál es el área
de este pedacito o de esta rebanada de
este círculo entero para sacarlo lo que
sería muy bueno empezar a pensar es que
parte o qué fracción es 30 grados de una
circunferencia entera una circunferencia
entera tiene 360 grados cuánto es 30
grados de 360 grados o dicho de otra
manera yo lo que quiero saber es cuánto
es 30 grados entre la circunferencia
entera que son 360 grados y bueno este 0
y este 0 se van y me queda 3 entre 36 si
yo saco tercera arriba y tercer abajo me
queda 1 entre 12 o dicho de otra manera
este pedazo es un doceavo de toda mi
circunferencia entera y si este pedacito
es un doceavo de todas las
circunferencias en teherán entonces
suena lógico que este pedazo de aquí que
es 6 por cierto sea un doceavo de toda
de todo el perímetro de mi
circunferencia o dicho de otra manera si
yo quiero sacar mi circunferencia y
circunferencia va a ser igual a 6 p qué
es lo que vale este pedacito déjenme
ponerlo con otro color 6 peak es lo que
vale este pedacito pero x 12 al
multiplicarlo por 12 voy a sacar toda la
circunferencia entera 6 x 12 y entonces
mi circunferencia es igual a 6 x 12 lo
cuales 60 más 12 que 72 y mi
circunferencia entera vale 72 y ahora ya
sé que toda esta circunferencia vale 72
pi el perímetro de este círculo vale 72
pi si yo sé la circunferencia entera
perímetro de este círculo habrá forma de
sacar su radio pues claro que sí porque
nosotros sabemos que la fórmula para
sacar el perímetro de un círculo es la
siguiente circunferencia es igual a dos
veces pin por el radio y yo por otra
parte sé que esto es igual a 72 pi que
es justo lo que tengo aquí arriba y si
ahora canceló este pin con este pin y
divido a ambos lados entre 2 voy a
llegar a que el radio es igual a 72
entre 2 lo cual es lo mismo que 36
perfecto ya con esto tenemos el radio
sin embargo vamos a ver que me preguntan
me preguntan cuál es el área del sector
p lo que queremos saber es cuál es esta
área que tenemos atrapada en este sector
y para sacar esta área qué te parece si
primero sacamos el área de este círculo
el área de este círculo es igual a pi
por radio elevado al cuadrado esta es la
fórmula que no sabemos de siempre y si
de aquí
sustituyó este radio me quedaría a que
el área es lo mismo que vi por el radio
elevado al cuadrado es decir por 36
elevado al cuadrado o dicho de otra
manera
36 por 36 ahora podemos sacar el área de
todo este círculo multiplicando 36 por
36 pero fíjate bien si yo lo que quiero
saber es el área de este sector p
entonces si nosotros sabemos que este
pedazo es un doceavo de la
circunferencia entera que te parece si a
esta área la dividimos entre 12 para
sacar el área de este sector es decir el
área del sector p es esto mismo entre 12
porque solamente nos vamos a tomar una
rebanada de las 12 que hay en esta
circunferencia y cuánto es esto pues 12
lo puedo cancelar con este 36 y aquí
arriba me quedan 3
estoy dividiendo entre 12 lo que está
arriba y entre 12 lo que está abajo
queda que el área de este sector es
igual a 3 por 36 lo cual es 90 + 18 que
es 108 108 por pi muy bien ya tengo el
área de este sector que es justo en la
respuesta que yo quería el área de este
pedacito de 108 pib que por cierto es el
inciso a entonces ya se me acabó el
tiempo y solamente nos falta un problema
para terminar esta sección 3 así que en
el siguiente vídeo voy a ver el último
problema de esta sección no te lo
pierdas